two American women and their dogs are
safe after a frightening ordeal at sea
the US Navy came to their rescue they
were stranded on a sailboat in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean for nearly
five months Latimer duthiers of our
streaming network cbsn has their
remarkable survival story glad good
morning good morning the pair had
planned quite an adventure just the two
of them and their pets on the journey of
a lifetime instead they ended up
stranded at sea desperately waiting to
be found until Tuesday when help finally
arrived sheer joy and relief this is the
moment Jennifer Appel and Tasha fou
Yabba were saved by the Navy after 147
days stranded at sea on May 3rd the
friend set sail from Hawaii to Tahiti
with their dogs Zeus and Valentine but
soon into the trip the rigging on their
masts broke a storm swamped their motor
and their communication system failed
bobbing helplessly in the Pacific
Jennifer and Tasha sent distress signals
each day they told CBS affiliate KGMB no
one heard their calls finally three days
ago they were found by a Taiwanese
fishing boat 900 miles southeast of
Japan thousands of miles off course
yesterday morning the USS Ashland
arrived this photo shows crewmembers
pulling Zeus to safety after a horrific
journey Tasha says they're now safe and
grateful for nearly five months Jennifer
and Tasha survived thanks to water
purifiers and a year supply of dry food
they will stay onboard the USS Ashland
with their pets until the ship's next
port of call and then I heard they want
to go back out on the water again I'm
thinking we're too
that's a thing no that's enough that's
enough tailors yeah boy yeah Congrats
our men and women in this room well so
glad thank you thank you glad